con su esposo sosteniendo la Biblia y
sus dos hijas mirando que tangie Brown
Jackson prestó juramento judicial el
jueves juró ante el juez que sustituye
Steven brayer que se retira a los 83
años la mujer de 51 años es la primera
afroamericana en servir en la Corte
Suprema de Estados Unidos y cuando el
senado confirmó su nominación en abril
rindió homenaje a los que le ayudaron a
llenar el camino
[Aplausos]
estoy aquí en nombre de las generaciones
de estadounidenses que nunca tuvieron
nada parecido a este tipo de
oportunidades
la jueza Jackson tiene una larga e
ilustre carrera jurídica y es experta en
justicia penal y disparidad en la
sentencias recientemente prestó servicio
en el tribunal del circuito de
Washington y es la primera ex defensora
pública que llega a ser jueza
Brown Jackson se incorpora tribunal en
un momento crítico con la fe del público
hacia la institución en un nivel bajo
tras su controvertido fallo para acabar
con el derecho constitucional al aborto
su juramento se produce el mismo día en
que el presidente byden criticó al
tribunal por su comportamiento
escandaloso en relación con esa decisión
lo primero y más importante que debemos
hacer es dejar en claro lo Escandalosa
que es esta decisión y el impacto que
tiene No solo en el derecho de la mujer
a elegir que es una pieza fundamental
crítica sino en la privacidad en general
pero para aquellos que esperan que la
jueza Jackson incline el tribunal hacia
la izquierda su incorporación no cambia
el equilibrio ideológico los
conservadores mantendrán su mayoría de 6
a 3